this podcast is brought to you by on it
go to audit.com and look at the great
selection of supplements if you find
something you like pressing code Joey
and get 10 off delivered right to your
house
check one two welcome to Uncle Joey's
Joy
[Music]
foreign
you bad [__] it's Thursday the
17th of November the joint is brought to
you by manscape listen to holiday season
is here and I'll be giving thanks to my
friends over at manscape manscape is
making sure you have everything you need
to stay fresh below the [__]
equator you don't want to go to
Grandma's with [__] your dick looking
like The Wolf Man so it's time to talk
the [__] manscape manscapes
performing package 4.0 has got it all
the lawnmower 4.0 body trimming weed
whacker the nose and ear hair remover
with skin safe technology to protect all
your [__] holes they're waterproof
and they have a light just in case the
power goes out right now get 20 off and
free shipping with code Joey at
manscape.com again 20 off and free
shipping with code Joey at manscape.com
that's 20 went off and free shipping
with code Joey at manscape.com be
thankful this holiday season trim your
balls and go out there and sling some
dick
Santa's coming the joint is also brought
to you by Blue chew wake up Salute the
flag and grab some blue true take it to
go [__] cause you never know when
you're gonna bump into a nice freak blue
chew is an online service that delivers
the same active ingredients as Viagra
and Cialis but in chewable tablets all
at a fraction of the cost
take them any time and be ready whenever
the opportunity arises I love blue chew
you pop one and you're ready to give
somebody a stabbing listen even if the
[__] pole works you still want to
have a little extra confidence when you
go in there and the process is simple
you sign up at bluetooth.com consult
with one of their licensed medical
providers and once you're approved
you'll receive your prescription within
days the best part is it's all done
online no [__] drama no doctor's
visits no awkward conversation no
standing online at the pharmacy
Bluetooth tablets are made in the US of
a and shipped in discrete packages so
you can benefit from extra confidence
when it's time to sling dick Bluetooth
can help try Bluetooth for free what are
you talking about Joey free when using
promo code Joey just pay five dollars
for shipping you're gonna enjoy
Bluetooth trust me bluetooth.com with
Coach Joey for your first month free
visit Bluetooth
dot com for more important safety
information I want to thank Bluetooth
for sponsoring The Joint let's get this
party started today
what's happening you bad [__]
it's Wednesday no Thursday the
[__] 17th of November we're a
week away
from Thanksgiving that's a [__]
reality and then
as soon as Thanksgiving is over as soon
as that football game is over on
Thursday
it you don't even have time to [__]
blink they just start shooting Christmas
at you Charlie Brown shows up with
cookies it's a Non-Stop six-weeker and
there's some people
like uh you know there's some people who
listen I love the holidays how can you
not
uh when I lived in La I tell you what
makes a big [__] difference living in
La about the holidays
and I never thought I would say this and
it's the biggest [__] is [__] I could
say
you want me to tell you what I'm not
gonna miss other holidays like that how
bad the holidays were for me for 23
years I didn't understand why and this
is the dumbest thing I came up with no
snow
it's hard
to jump up and down and sing Jingle
Bells when it's [__] 65 degrees
outside it really is guys I had a really
hard time with that and before I even
said made this statement I just wanted
to think about like if you grew up in
Florida or if you grew up in Texas or if
you grew up in places that you didn't
have snow for Christmas then you really
don't understand but you always do want
to see a Christmas with [__] snow so
it's kind of weird how
I was talking about this the other day I
think what my wife about like the
differences in the holidays like the
last two holidays that we've had here
the first holiday we were in [__]
limbo we didn't know what to do and then
last year the holiday was better but I I
got covered the 24th of [__] December
so but still the feeling is better when
you like I still remember the holidays
in Colorado oh my God in Snowmass
Village you could smell the wood burning
stoves and in the air and the [__]
snow everywhere and that really makes a
[__] difference when you're trying to
push a winter wonderland you know in
California you're pushing a winter
wonderland but the [__] sun is out
and people going to the goddamn Beach so
it really really [__] uh
like you don't even know until you're
out of it like how much I was affected
by just the sunshine on Christmas you
want it to be snowy at Christmas day you
want the sun to be out I was telling
somebody somebody was asking about
Colorado my last Christmas in Colorado I
guys it snowed check it out go look it
up
December 24th of
1994 it must have snowed three [__]
feet
two and a half feet like one of those
snow storms where everything is locked
in forget your [__] car if you don't
have snow boots you're in no danger if
you don't have those things like Eskimos
and two poles you're in no [__]
Danger and I'll never forget this man
[__] Christmas day it was [__]
70 degrees
like I remember going to work freezing
and coming out of work and everything
was melted all the [__] Irish
Boulevard was it looked like a [__]
Lake it was like three inches on the
streets [__] it was tremendous but
yeah without snow man it really makes to
a [__] uh hard holiday and I never
knew that and I know some people are
[__] thinking about what I said right
now but it makes a difference if you
grow up in the northeast or with snow
like if you grew up in Montana or
something like that you got [__] snow
but then you leave that and I don't
think you notice a difference like when
I went to Colorado I didn't really
[__] notice a difference push this
[__] snow in the summer in Colorado
but uh it's been a good week so far I'm
excited for the show next week in
Philadelphia I've always loved
Philadelphia uh Parks Casino is great
they got great food Lee's coming down
I'm excited
[__] Parks Casino last time I went to
Parks I had a blast blast and I didn't
gamble I think I played like five bucks
in the roulette if anything about Philly
that always gets me is the [__]
people
the people in Philly are like nowhere
else in the [__] country I was
looking at my joke list the other night
for Philly it's dirty I mean who gives a
[__] you know Philly you could throw
anything at him you'll never get booed
in Philly well I shouldn't say that they
booed Bill Burr and he became a [__]
star when they unboot him but you know
yeah they unboot them and [__] that was
great when Bill did that that was
[__] great years ago that's when I
knew bill was a star I'm like this
[__] kid just broke the [__]
barrier but this week I had some
interesting [__] happen and I was
talking to Mike when he came in
guys I'm a [__] idiot and I'm really
proud to say that I I don't walk around
with any [__] illusions of whatever
guys I'm an idiot I talk to other people
and I see how intelligent they are and
how you know but I'm a [__] idiot
it's funny because yesterday I was
watching in fact I put it up as one of
my stories because it was so inspiring
to me it was Mike Tyson talking about
Roberto Duran
and it's probably the same reason I've
always looked up to Roberto Duran and he
always made me feel comfortable because
he's a [__] Savage
okay Roberto Duran wasn't raised in a
parents in a [__] home that was warm
and they had three meals a day and they
said prayers Roberto Duran was raised in
a scary [__] way I've read two
Roberto Duran books
and I relate I understand he says some
[__] that is [__] crazy the craziest
thing he ever [__] did in my world
and I mean
was before he fought Sugar Ray Leonard
he saw him on the streets of Toronto and
Sugar Ray had his wife and his family
with him and they went up to him like
you know like with normal nice
people do like you know
and they didn't know Roberto Duran was a
[__] animal
and I guess
sugar went to give his hand out of
something and he [__] told him to go
[__] himself I'm gonna [__] your wife in
the ass dog he threw a tantrum on him
that Sugar Ray never even established
before he went into that fight and he
lost he was all [__] confused or
brother Duran kept saying [__] to him
Roberto Duran is a [__] animal and I
tell people all the time listen man
I'm a nice guy to a degree but once you
cross that thing I'll say [__] to you
that'll make you [__] ice cross and I
don't want to do that I don't want to be
that guy so don't get me [__] going
you know
but uh I've always
considered myself not the most
intelligent guy I'm very Street versed
and my language is straight my my uh
my open twice Street which is you know
yeah it's gone away from me from me
getting better roles and to get to
better places in my life it was always
uh
I hang in the nail whatever the [__]
they call it but uh
I've lived with it you know and the
proof isn't the pudding I got left back
in the seventh grade I got a GED you
know the proof isn't the [__] pudding
I can't fix a car I can't change a flat
on a bicycle there's a thousand things I
can't do that I wish I could [__] do
you know and it just you go to live with
it so after all these years by the age
of by the time I got out of the hole and
the prison I was in and all this [__]
came to the conclusion that I wasn't the
smartest guy in the world okay
but I had just as much heart
as the [__] guy next to me and I
always felt that that would keep me in
the game or take me just as far as him
as having heart and belief not letting
anything get in your [__] way
so
you know when I look into things when I
come to you when I go hey man I'm
thinking of starting a podcast
and you tell me the advice to start a
podcast I'm I'm really taking advice
from you when I go to somebody and I go
hey man
I I want to do this but I don't know how
to get it to the next level one of the
most frustrating things
in this career that I've had is being
able knowing that you're able to do this
that you're able to [__] handle this
and people not giving you the
opportunity to help you to get to get to
that goal
it's a shitty [__] feeling so
a shitty feeling for about three [__]
minutes until you go you know what
[__] these [__] they don't want
to help me I'm gonna do it my [__]
way and you develop a system that works
for you I.E when I was [__] a young
you know I went to LA and I was learning
the acting game I didn't like the [__]
that they were sending me out on and I
didn't like the [__] that I was you know
I didn't like it all together so I said
I gotta go out for rolls and a
better for me so I started looking not
on breakdowns but I started looking at
movies and [__] like that in
pre-production
and I would see where they were being
shot if it was a New York movie a
Connecticut movie anything with this I
would submit packages what's that a tape
a [__] uh I wouldn't submit a tape of
stand up I put a tape in there of the
audition for that movie uh a [__] two
tickets to a comedy show I would put the
whole thing in there bio different
headshots I would give them everything
so they wouldn't come back to me
but I would do it unsolicited and a lot
of people told me they're like Joey
that's not cool
for you to [__] again the people that
don't know and don't have any hustle
would say to me that's not cool you're
overstepping your bounds and I go you
know what man
the casting director's job is to find
the right person for that project even
if it isn't me I gotta let her know that
I exist
and I did that for years and people like
dog you're gonna piss off a lot of
people somebody's gonna say some people
guess what it got me the longest shot
and then it got me American Gangster and
then it got me [__] taxi all those
movie roles that you saw at the time in
the 2003 four five six it wasn't because
I was on fire it was because I was
sending those envelopes
and people always said to me well Joe
you know you got to piss somebody off
guess what I think one person said
something to me and the damage was
already done I don't give a [__]
so my point is that we always are
looking for help
and nobody wants to give it to you so
some people quit what they were gonna do
because they don't know it's like when I
when I decide to do stand up there was
no [__] computer
there was no [__] internet I didn't
know any comedians there wasn't the
abundance of comedians that there is
today every three people you talk to
their Comics now I never saw anything
like this every three people I talked to
now oh my nephew's a comic my sister's a
comic I got nothing against you but
there was nothing nobody to go to and go
hi Mike
I want to do stand-up comedy oh let me
take you to the ropes I had to buy Judy
Carter's book and then I had to get to
the gates and when you get there the
scariest thing you could do is when
people start talking to you when you
start asking questions and [__] like
this they'll start saying oh okay yeah
we'll help you out once people know
you're real that you're putting the work
in don't answer your [__] questions
but there was tons of times when
I didn't know what to do
I was stuck so I just said [__] it I sat
there for three days feeling sorry for
myself as we do as Americans as we do as
human beings and that that I said [__]
this I'm gonna attack it this [__]
way you just think about it
but then there's things that you cannot
do that for
and that's what brings me to this it's
we wrote a book guys
it took me [__] 10 years to write a
chapter I finally meet a friend of mine
to help me she does a [__] phenomenal
job
we get everything going and I get a
letter to the another letter I got an
email last week a call a text when I'm
in [__] wakanda forever
and it's that they want this and they
want that at 5 30 on a Friday so I got a
little hot I'm like come on guys would
you call your mother at 5 30 on a
[__] Friday to ask for all this [__]
the week's over
but what they wanted was for me to
change the kidnapping story of my book
and I'm like come on guys I already told
this [__] story I can't change the
people the people who want to buy this
book have been listening to me for years
and they're like well we kind of shorten
it maybe we can get some release signs
they want me to get a release sign from
the kidnapper the other guy did well and
the guy I kidnapped now here's how I
look at it guys
I could probably get a release from
Valor but I don't want to and I'll tell
you what
development went through enough fella
went through enough I kidnapped them
they got kidnapped by somebody else then
he got beat up by somebody else Bella
was in it to win it and uh you know the
fella was in it to win it and he's got
his life together now he's in [__]
Arizona he's doing great he makes great
money he's thinking of moving to New
Mexico but his mom just passed away
about a year ago and he was a mama's boy
and I just don't wanna you know I'm I'm
friends with him finally I don't want to
send it or call him up and go hey man I
want to send you this thing I want to
write a book and
so I just told him I go listen guys why
are we doing all this [__] it's public
knowledge first of all they go can you
have two people who could recount your
story I go I go three people that can
recount it fella who I don't want to
bother my ex-wife who's gonna hang up on
you and [__] Georgie George you could
tell you from the outside what was going
on but he can't tell you he wasn't in
the room with me and all this [__]
so I just told him right now you know I
listened to him talking and this is what
I'm trying to explain to you that
I'm a [__] dumb [__] you know I got
all the prerequisites of a [__] dummy
and I know that going in I I know this
going it I'm not trying to put a an
intelligent cap on my head so when I'm
around people I don't know [__] about
whether it's a book
whether it's a guitar whether it's
listen I only know about stand-up comedy
how to eat ass I don't even know I eat
ass properly because yeah
so
that's all I could do so anytime I come
to that I always step out and I ask
people and you you guys have heard me
constantly I don't like to do things
wrong
and what happens is if you do something
on your own you're going to pick up
habits
and then you have to get rid of those
[__] Habits Like the gum the thumb
with the guitar they don't want to see
the [__] thumb lurking you know and
then I watch slash and all you see is
this [__] thumb but I get it because
when you start that's a thing that you
don't want it's like when you start
comedy they want you to start clean
there's a reason for that because if you
start dirty then you can't go back to
clean at least start clean at least do
topical jokes
and then as you get more experience you
get dirty but that's not what we're
talking about
I [__] hate going into a room and
being a know-it-all
so what I've done and I've told Mike
this for years guys you have no idea
in the 23 years now how many meetings I
went to and at first I was very green
and I would shut my mouth and listen and
try to learn and then as the years went
you know I was a [__] Coke fiend who
wants to hear from a [__] Coke friend
not me so I would go I'd smile I'd be at
Pilates can be but I knew I had nothing
to [__] off of these people but then
as I got more experience I started going
into these table reads and into these
pitch meetings and [__] and guys
I would sit there and [__] awe of the
stupidity in the world and I hate to use
that word
but I thought that these people were so
[__] much smarter than I am and at
the end of the day I got to like break
like I can just take so much like I
could just take so much you could talk
stupidity in front of me for so so
[__] much and it was like this
conversation the other day I had the
attorney that guy got more school than
me he had another attorney in the room
the [__] publisher was on the [__]
phone and a chick that worked for the
assistant publisher and they'd give me
all these ultimatums and I'm like guys
stop they're like well why don't you and
Joey go get the paperwork from Boulder
like call Boulder and go through the
paperwork to get you because it's public
knowledge if you [__] gets hit in the
head with a poll and the cops come it's
public [__] knowledge they have to
write a report and it's in there and
that's just the way it is and you can go
down to the police station at any time
and [__] read it I don't know what
the protocols are but you could read it
and how do I know this because [__]
like 15 years ago I was trying to get my
passport
and the attorney I was using said what
we'll do is let's get the paperwork from
this and that to show them they
well I read my [__] kidnapping case
let me tell you something guys when I
read this [__] thing of what I'd done
like what had happened on November 18th
I cried
I cried because I didn't even know who
that person was
it was like reading the paper and
reading about a crime that somebody had
committed and it's not even a friend of
yours like just reading about somebody
and going boy
that was a rough [__] day that that
dude did some damage you know what I'm
saying like this guy robbed the bank
shot four people engine eight one of
those things you know like this guy's a
friend of yours so I vote after I read
that police report about what happened
on November 18th guys I gotta tell you
the first time I read that after like
you know not being around there for 20
years
if I can brought a tail to my eye I was
like
wow but then again that was the report
that they had to write to [__] you
know it made it very colorful and all
this [__] but when you read it it's very
[__] disturbing unless I told them I
go guys I told you a [__] story that
happened on November 18th
obviously you guys want to get somebody
to collaborate with you I I can't go to
these people to collaborate them they
wanted me to go to
they wanted me to collaborate a story
from 1975.
and I'm like guys
everybody in that conversation except
for me is [__] dead
that that what are you talking about
they're like okay forget about that one
let's go back to the kidnapping okay
what do you want to know and they're
like well what we want you to do is go
and I said let's stop this you got two
attorneys right yeah why don't you
contact Boulder it'll be a lot easier
you could read the [__] report
that'll let you know everything that you
need to know but I give you a warning
when you read that report you won't be
calling me back
I'm telling you once you read that
report you won't be calling me back
because the report is that buck wild but
it'll collaborate my story plus a couple
other [__] things in there that might
blow you the [__] away so and they were
like okay
let's do that do you know that the next
day they contacted me again and said do
you think we could get
[__] uh
collaboration papers from the guy you
kidnapped plus the guy that again they
came back to me and I'm like are you
[__] kidding me
so
but to get back to it guys
you know I respect college so much I
really do I don't know if I respect it
because I didn't graduate I don't know
if I respect that because I didn't do it
the right way
when somebody tells me that college
educated I give them a little leeway
they did something I couldn't do and I
did something they couldn't do
they went to a four-year college and put
up with all that [__] and did homework
and studied and and now they're working
in their field
I never understood when I went to these
[__] meetings for Hollywood
how four years even at Syracuse which is
a big television school and film school
and all that stuff how these people
would apply that to make the decisions
they make in these rooms and to give you
the feedback
that they give you in some of these
[__] rooms you sit there and go
what the [__] did they just say
like I sold one show to Fox
they had
I sold them and here's the other thing
about these book these movie these
people when you shoot a special to all
you young comics
when you shoot a special they're going
to come see you whether it's Netflix
whether it's uh any other three of the
four companies that do it all who's ever
putting the special to get this is the
best I love all this [__] when they come
to you they offered to you
and they say listen
we want to offer you this special we're
going to air it on this
and you go you're trying to be honest
with them
you go listen before you uh have any
plans on airing this have you ever heard
the story of me sleeping with a
one-legged woman
and they'll go yeah we heard it on Tom
seguro I turned it into a bit and it's
in the middle of my set we have a
problem no that's a brilliant bed oh my
God we're so excited we can't wait for
you to see it
all right you signed the paperwork they
give you the deposit for the special
and then about let's say you have 12
weeks from the time you shoot a special
after about six weeks you get a call
from your agent they want to come watch
your set one night they want to come see
your hours set see how it's shaping up
to see if
you know what can we yank out the [__]
with this [__]
and on that night when you get off stage
they'll be in the back waiting for you
oh my God
that was the best thing we've ever seen
in our lives just sitting there going I
was the worst side of my life but
whatever you think
it was great this that this you know the
special sucked and you're waiting for
notes
and they'll hit you with an obscure note
like in the beginning you said the word
[__] can you uh turn that into
something else okay you know you you
know you're not gonna [__]
listen you know you're not gonna change
it okay you just yes I'm the dead yeah
yeah I'll change it it was like when Tom
Segura did his Netflix special with
President Netflix called him up and
[__] made him write an apology to
Special Olympics or some [__] yeah and
he had to take [__] out of their
special and all this [__] anyway
so
like what [__] kid watches [__]
Netflix specials anyway
so and I don't mean to put this in a bad
way guys but it's the [__] truth
so then you go see them they'll come see
you like three weeks out
maybe two weeks I was so excited okay
they come down with that [__] and
that's when they'll say it to you you
know what
we think the one-legged joke might be a
little too your agent calls you with
that [__] and you're like yeah well
too [__] bad
and they'll hit you again with it while
we think that if you could shave that
off can you say that she had a leg now
they're trying to tell you how to write
a joke
that's the best when they're trying to
tell you how to do your [__] job when
they can't even do this it takes eight
people to make a [__] decision but
you're doing your job on your [__]
you know Merit
and now you gotta [__] war going on
well they think they want you to take
the bid out
okay just like that it's that magical
I'm not taking it out and you go back
and forth back and forth back and forth
and hey you could be a [__] [__]
and take it out
or B you could take that [__] joke go
out there and rip them [__] apart
with that joke and many others of that
vein watch the audience laugh and then
look at them and go what the [__] were
you people talking about
and that's what people do they always
expect to be they do what the [__]
they're gonna do and that's just the way
it is they'll let you think that yeah
I'm gonna do a set about dandelions go
[__] yourself I'm doing this I'm going
all deep on this [__] and this
happened this week I just watched that
thing about two days ago maybe no
yesterday I watched it it was uh the
Chappelle thing outside of that live
you know it was a great set
it was a great set and guess what we
needed that set
as America we needed that [__] see
for 2 000 years comedy is the [__]
what's the subtitles of our life
okay and not subtitles are your
particular life but subtitles of Life of
what's going on whether it's Russia
bombing people Ukraine bombing people
the War uh you know [__] uh all the
[__] all of a sudden you got 20
million Jew haters you know so we try
yeah all of a sudden everybody's [__]
hating on the Jews I don't understand so
what we try to do is go up there you
hear the news right and then you got
Daily News which adds a little humor to
it and then we go up there and try to
really [__] humor it up so it doesn't
feel like you know anything
like you've not heard anything
but it's really a war going on our job
is like when you watch uh
you know he wasn't one of my favorite
[__] guys something about him always
but his stand-up was a voice of a
[__] Nation not Richard Pryor but the
other guy the white dude that died Colin
Colin's voice was a [__] voice of the
nation I don't care what anybody [__]
tells you he was the voice of a Nation
he
told you it's like I like to watch 60
minutes because it's Layman's show
it's the news I need to [__] hear I
don't need to hear about all this other
I don't need to hear about a lady in the
Bronx who put a baby in the oven I
really don't need to hear that [__] in
the morning nobody does nobody no I'm
not trying to make a joke nobody [__]
needs to make that hear that [__] so
uh
you know you that's why I watched 60
minutes when you watch a comic a good
comic not like me but a good comic that
is very socially uh aware Neil Brennan's
the
couple guys Neil Brennan's new special
is great too by the way and Harvey
special is [__] fantastic I've
watched Ari special twice say what you
want to say
as a comic that's a great [__]
special I'm very proud of him very proud
to call him my friend but
I found that that ship like what first
of all the set was a great set there was
no reason he just listen we all we're
all mad not we but they're all mad at
Kanye even though they know that he's
[__] crazy he just doesn't take his
meds and he goes off and this has been
going on for years yeah you want to
punish him whatever but the [__] the
scars are a lot deeper than what you see
with Kanye like me the scars are a lot
deeper he just gets to talk about that
[__] more that's what Dave did was
pretty much you know made a [__] joke
about it whatever I didn't watch it live
I didn't even know Dave Chappelle was
going to be on Saturday night [__]
live and then you know all first they
were boycotting them you know the
writers threatened the boycott them and
all this [__] for you boycott
[__] do me a favor knock it off
knock it off
knock it off knock it off and watch the
Bronx Bronx Tale nobody cares
nobody cares when are you gonna put that
to your [__] head people that nobody
cares you ever turn on Instagram and go
through the first 28 people talking like
you know trying to tell you and listen
that's great I appreciate that you have
the voice you couldn't do this in Cuba
but nobody [__] gives a [__] so knock
it the [__] off nobody [__] cares so
please enough with the [__] [__]
of the [__] boycotting and whatever
you're just gonna put yourself in even a
worse you're gonna feel a lot worse than
what you already feel because now
they're gonna let you obviously know how
they really feel about you that they
don't give a [__] with you get up
whether you leave you take your chubby
friend with the pink hair and get the
[__] out of here we don't need you
[__] in here enough is enough
nobody cares go find the [__] Island
where everybody's walking everybody
gives a [__] about your world but right
now it's not [__] working I'm Sorry
Charlie sorry what do you want me to do
that's the truth it's not working you
gotta keep boycotting saves your ballot
throwing them out of the theaters listen
we're always going to find the [__]
place to perform
these Comics will always find the place
to perform they're that [__] crafty
so if Athena doesn't want to hire me
because three years ago I said something
bad who gives a [__] go [__] yourself
it's that simple look at Ari shafia two
years ago nobody want to talk to him now
look at him he's still a great [__]
stand-up comic whatever's going on in
this and his social Stratosphere that's
his [__] beef if he don't like
somebody but as a comic you want to come
to me and that's what we're forgetting
when we [__] try to tell everybody
how these people have insulted you
they're [__] comics
they're comedians
they're comedians where's your [__]
head at
so but this is what we got to deal with
today where's your hat at the comedians
Joe Rogan's given misinformation did he
have to say he was a scientist did he
ever say he was a [__] astronomer or
an astronaut no he's not so why the [__]
are you bitching at people
yeah Dave Chappelle
they're mad at Dave because he went up
there and did a a a second set like he
did a set for the networks and that's
what you do as a professional
you do a set for the [__] Networks
and you make them happy they go in the
back and then you come out there and
[__] stab them did anybody not see
the movie Elvis that Elvis and you see
Elvis Elvis does that they tell him not
to [__] wiggle they tell them not to
wiggle not to do all this [__] and then
from there they throw him into the army
I don't know if that story is factual or
not but I got a thousand stories Like
That We're Not Gonna Bend for you trust
me what I'm telling you if I go up on
stage and you say and there's a burn
victim in the audience Jay Leno's in the
audience or some [__] and you tell me
not to make any burn victim jokes I'm
not gonna make a joke at Jay Leno I like
Jay but I'm gonna make a burn victim
joke it's who the [__] I am
and people kind of get over this [__]
it's not working
listen if you don't like the comedians
don't go on [__] Netflix
if you don't like you know
I love what people were [__] saying
about this Chappelle thing also
that Chapel could have done an hour and
a half that may would have been way
better than what cyanide live was gonna
[__] put up there
I mean that's as cold-blooded to say I
know those young comedians work hard and
stuff
but it's the truth
that's what the sensors have done to
real comedy they've watered down watered
down water then if you're going to tell
me that Alec Baldwin As Trump was funny
is that what you're telling me was very
into it was very entertaining
that that was the funniest thing you
ever saw no what
no it wasn't
sound life tricks you with that [__]
bread and butter stupid comedy and you
believe it that's not the comedy world
at all that's just some dudes doing
sketches and that's the way it's been
for the last 20 [__] years nobody
gives a [__] about that show so for all
you sound like people that get offended
or want to boycott all that [__] who
gives a [__] real Comics are not that's
it Comics are done guys I talk to a lot
of these guys they're like you know what
we don't give a [__]
you can't do nothing no more we're
uncancelable who gives a [__] about you
if you get offended or something we did
30 [__] years ago it was so funny I
had to take a long ride the other day I
was thinking about
all the [__] that came out when we have
a chance
like all this [__] that started coming
out started coming out two months after
the pandemic this guy raped me this guy
did this this guy did that why because
we had time to think
and all those people in the
entertainment business think about it if
you get [__] raped if any other woman
gets [__] raped she reported to the
police immediately
she'll say this to somebody immediately
I have a daughter I have a wife I have
you know but all of a sudden they
remembered two months after the pandemic
was home and they had nothing going on
when all they had to stare at was
[__] four [__] walls you know and
it's the same [__] thing
people are still thinking of new ways
now to just mess with people you can do
the if Jesus listened to me if Jesus
came down today and did a stand-up set
three people would find a [__]
problem with that
um if he didn't stand up on Sunday
Monday morning on all the [__] social
media the national Federation of priests
molested priest had a problem with what
he said you know it's it's and at the
end of the day guys
again for put you on the under the list
of the boycotters nobody gives a [__]
Dave Chappelle is going to go somewhere
else this weekend and make another
million dollars and you that's
complaining and you know what are you
gonna do this weekend sit there and
complain about other [__] stand-ups
and other [__] TV shows and it's a
[__] nightmare out there but hey
that was what I want to talk about today
was just
sometimes man you think you're the
dumbest person in the room
and you're really [__] not and it
happens to me
constantly especially when I'm talking
to people about business and stuff I
don't have an MBA I have nothing in
business everything I've learned has
been the last [__] 20 years [__]
around with social media and you guys
talking to you like everybody else we
don't know nothing else I have no
[__] idea what's going on but you
know it's like everybody's always trying
to tell you the best whether it's books
when it comes to you in your world you
know best and fight for that right don't
you say okay okay okay I'll let it ride
this time no because the word gets out
it's like any [__] thing else fight
for your [__] right to do whatever
the [__] you're doing I remember being
an electrician I had a fight every day
and all the things that has bothered me
the last
20 years of my [__] career is that
it's dealing with people who told you
they knew what was going on and then one
day you're like what the [__] are you
talking about and you blow right past
them and you're like why did I ever
think in life that guy was smarter than
me or he knew what he was doing more
than I did
so you got to go with your [__] gut
guys don't let these people [__]
knock you off your track I don't and I
haven't even when I was doing coke in a
[__] junk in a criminal I wouldn't
let people throw me off my track if you
have belief [__] go for it and if you
[__] think you're doing the right
thing go for it if not you're gonna find
out the hard way you were wrong and who
gives a [__] I was wrong for [__] 30
years and here we are right or wrong so
take it off suck your [__] dick and
that's it [__] I got nothing
else to say on a beautiful [__]
Thursday we're a week away from
Thanksgiving and like I've been telling
you guys right now listen to me the year
is dead
we're going to do the rest of whatever
the [__] we do till December 31st but
what you're doing is you're setting up
your 2023 like I told the guys on my
patreon last week when you shoot pool
you don't shoot pool to make that ball
you shoot pool to make the ball and to
set you up for the next shot right now
we're just setting up 2023. you're gonna
get all this [__] done and listen I know
you want to lose weight you know what
what are you going to do you want to
start [__] beating yourself up now
what I want you to do is if you want to
start losing if you want to go on a
[__] great diet
January 1st right now but prepare for
2023 early it's going to be a rough
[__] year and things are going to go
[__] sour they want two dollars and
fifty cents for a can of cranberry juice
cranberry sauce
did you see that that's the biggest it's
been in the last 30 years it's been a
dollar 39 for 200 [__] years now they
want two dollars and fifty [__] cents
for [__] cranberry sauce
that Joe was complaining the other day
his wife went to groceries she spent 350
000 came back with one [__] bad guy
so listen like I said on the podcast the
other day it's gonna be a tight year do
not be embarrassed it's the holidays the
holidays aren't about gifts it's about
love anyway just be prepared to give it
a lot of handshakes for Christmas
and to get a lot of handshakes back this
year
but just keep your head and know that
2023 is going to be a better year write
your goals do what you need to do and I
love you [__] I'll see you back
here on the joint Monday morning Tip Top
Magoo stay black have a great weekend
and I'll see you [__] Monday
morning
all right I want to thank you
[__] it was a short one today I
was not in the [__] bestest state of
mind but hey we showed up and I did the
best I could do I want to thank Mike I
want to thank all you [__] but
I want to thank manscape for sponsoring
the podcast let me tell you something
manscape wants to make sure you got
everything you need to stay fresh under
the [__] belt okay I've been talking
about manscape for years it's time you
[__] [__] or get off the [__] pot
this thing's Gonna Change Your Life
manscape performance package 4.0 it's
got it all the lawnmower the 4.0 body
trimming weed whacker [__] creams the
throw a pair underwear a [__] leather
bag listen it's all waterproof and the
[__] manscape performance trimmer
comes with a [__] light too get 20
off and free shipping with Coach Joey at
manscape again 20 off from free shipping
with code Joey at manscape be thankful
this holiday season for the best gift of
all manscapes and your balls will thank
you
is also brought to you by bluetooth wake
up Salute the flag and grab the blue
chew blue chew is an online service that
delivers the same active ingredients as
Viagra and Cialis but in chewable
tablets all at a fraction of the cost
take them any time and be ready whenever
the opportunity arises listen blue true
is great and it's simple okay you put it
in your [__] pocket put in your glove
compartment whatever and if you bump
into something you can always welcome
the extra [__] an inch or two in the
hardness you understand me the best part
of blue shoe is it's all done online no
doctor visits no awkward conversations
you don't gotta stay in the pharmacy
Bluetooth tablets are made in the US of
a and shipped a discreet package if you
could benefit from extra confidence when
it's trying to perform Bluetooth can
help try Bluetooth for free when using
Code Joey and pay five dollars for
shipping that's bluetooth.com called
Joey for your first month free visit
bluetooth.com for all the important
information all right [__] I
love you to death I want to thank
Bluetooth manscaping better help and CBD
lion but I want to thank you guys for
always having my back have a great
weekend stay black
foreign
[Music]